يقول قصر باكنغهام إن
الانتماءات العسكرية للأمير أندروز ورعايته الملكية
قد أعيدت إلى
الملكة وفقًا لبيان أن
دوق يورك سيستمر في عدم
القيام بأي واجبات عامة
ويدافع عن هذه القضية بصفته مواطنًا خاصًا
مراسلات CNN الملكية ماكس فوستر
ينضم إلينا  عش الآن ،
ما الذي يعنيه هذا
جيدًا ، لقد كان هناك قدر هائل من
الضغط على القصر من قبل
الجيش على وجه الخصوص لمعالجة هذه
المشكلة التي لا تزال تحظى
برعاية ملكية للأمير أندروز مما يعني أنه
لا يزال يمثل وحدات معينة
داخل الجيش وكان هناك  الكثير من
الإحراج لأنهم أرادوا منه
أن يتراجع وكان
هناك رسالة اليوم إلى الملكة من أه
العسكريين القدامى يطلبون أن يكون
هذا هو الحال ما لديك هنا
هو حالة يذهب فيها الأمير أندرو
أه حالات  المضي قدمًا ضده في
قضية اعتداء وهي تنعكس على
النظام الملكي ولا يزال لديه
دور عام على الرغم من أنه "  لقد تراجعت عن
واجباته العامة ، فلديه هذه
المناصب العامة
، ومن الواضح أن الملكة تقول إنني
سأقرأ لك البيان الذي
يخبرنا به بموافقة الملكة وموافقتها ،
لذا قررت الملكة
[الموسيقى
] أن هذا ليس أميرًا.  أندرو
يتراجع بالضرورة ، نحتاج إلى
النظر أكثر في الأمر ، لكن هذه خطوة كبيرة
نيابة عنها
،
فقد أعيدت الانتماءات العسكرية لدوق يورك والرعايات الملكية
إلى الملكة لم يعد يمثل
الملكة ولم يعد جزءًا فعالاً من الملكة.
الملكية العامة ، الشركة التي
لا يزال بالطبع عضوًا في العائلة المالكة ،
لكنه لم يعد جزءًا من الشركة
بعد الآن بسبب هذه الحالة في
نيويورك ، سيستمر دوق يورك في عدم
القيام بأي واجبات عامة
ويدافع عن قضيته كمواطن عادي
لذا فهم يبتعدون عن أنفسهم ،
فالملكية البريطانية تنأى
بنفسها عن الأمير ، ويقولون إنهم
يقولون إننا لا يمكن أن نشارك في هذه
العملية ولكن لا يمكننا فعلاً أن نكون كذلك
متورطًا مع الأمير أندرو أيضًا ، إنها
لحظة مهمة للغاية ، فأنا
أفهمها أيضًا وسنحصل على المزيد
حول هذا لاحقًا أنه ستكون هناك
بعض التغييرات الأخرى على لقبه الرسمي
والتي تعكس ذلك
وأيضًا كيف أن الأعضاء الآخرين في  ستتحمل العائلة
المالكة هذه المسؤوليات
بشكل أساسي لإظهار دوام
هذه الخطوة ، فهذه ليست خطوة مؤقتة إلى الوراء
بينما ننتظر نتيجة من
قضية نيويورك ، فهذا قرار دائم
لطرد الأمير وإسقاطه
من الشركة كما يسمونه  يبقى جزء من العائلة في النظام الملكي